juilliard and you've done all these
plays and worked with the greatest
and so and then who would ever thought
you'd become this
uh amazing this extensive voiceover
career
like that that's like has made you
famous in so many ways right what was
the likelihood of
a new york actor who
primarily did classics i worked for joe
papp at the public
san diego shakespeare hartford stage did
a lot of regional theater did a lot of
theater
on broadway and off-broadway but a
classically trained actor what were the
odds
of the first
animated audition he's invited to do
is the animation of batman the first
audition i went on
for a voiceover and you didn't even want
to audition for that role i wanted to
audition for
for bullock because i thought those are
the character the character
i could be a really good character i
thought that would be a more
fun character and because of the kind of
roles i played
edgar in lear edmond in lear um
achilles orestes uh prince hal
all of these classic epic heroes that
the one role they would want me to read
for is
batman who is of all the dc characters
of all the animated universe he
is a classic shakespearean type of actor
his whole life drama is a greek drama i
mean it's so
epic it's so his parents killed
is right yeah it's a great drama when
bruce tim
was describing to me the character
because the only batman i knew was the
adam west batman from the 60s and bruce
said no no no that's not what we're
doing we lo everyone loves adam west but
that's not what we're doing
he said no and he described to me the
character the tragedy of the background
so i just put myself into you know just
putting my imagination in the booth i
went to this place
and you know this dark kind of rooty
voice and i sort of found this character
just
in the audition just improvising and
they essentially hired me on the spot
they'd seen over 500 people
and i found out from andrea afterwards
the casting director andre romano who we
love
that i had been recommended by a new
york casting agent
anthony borneo who she knew
because she said to anthony i'm going
crazy i can't find a batman
we've seen hundreds of people and he
said well there's this really
interesting
new york actor who does classics and
he might be really interesting to you so
that's the kind of chance
that wouldn't happen now
because everything's stunt casted now
everything's about starcasting
they were willing to look at an actor
that no one had ever heard of
but who had the right instinct for the
role
and brought the character to life i
honestly
don't think i would probably get the
role today
um and that's the sad thing about the
way the business has evolved
but that was such a lucky moment for me
because it was also the first show where
they broke
away from that daytime goofy
um broad cartoony anime
animation that had been done while we
were kids growing up
and they were willing to go to this dark
dramatic epic film noir
incredible scripts full symphony score
big cast of actors i mean
it was like doing a movie every week it
was such a huge departure for
warner brothers and the only reason they
did it was because gene mccurdy wanted
to do it
and bruce tim uh wanted to do it and
eric gragonski
and paul deeney all the people that got
involved
were so excited about doing this but
they knew they were doing something
revolutionary it hadn't been done